US president has declared a national
emergency over the corona virus pandemic
as the number of cases raises across the
country Donald Trump described the next
eight weeks as critical to fighting the
respiratory illness he said half a
million coronavirus tests will be
available as early as next week and
urged every state to set up emergency
centers to treat patients
to unleash the full power of the federal
government in this effort today I am
officially declaring a national
emergency two very big words the action
I am taking will open up access to up to
fifty billion dollars of very
importantly very important and a large
amount of money for states and
territories and localities and our
shared fight against this disease in
furtherance of the order emerging every
state to set up emergency operation
centers effective immediately I'm also
asking every hospital in this country to
activate its emergency preparedness plan
so that they can meet the needs of
Americans everywhere so what does this
practically mean now on the ground and
for Americans Kimberly well what it
means is that there's going to be a lot
more money now to blunt the outbreak
here in the United States we now have
more than 1,900 cases of corona virus in
at least 46 states with at least 41
deaths so there is a real interest of
public health officials who spoke in the
Rose Garden alongside the US president
to try and combat this outbreak and so
they're doing it in a number of ways not
only by declaring a national emergency
which frees up tens of billions for the
federal government to coordinate with
the state and local governments but also
we saw the president surrounded by a
number of key industry officials from
the private sector and what the
president has done has kind of taken his
transactional approach to government
which we've seen in the past and this is
no exception in bringing in industry
leaders from from private companies like
Google for example even Walmart setting
up a website so that Americans can
easily on a smartphone access whether or
not a they need a test and B if they do
where to get it setting up in parking
lots around the United States different
areas where people can go and get this
test in a very American style in their
cars they'll be drive through type
swabbing that will be taking place so
this is something that the president is
saying will take place
by the end of this weekend the in terms
of the website being set up with the
tasks some five hundred thousand of them
by the middle of the week now he also
said that there may be up to five
million tests ultimately available
saying and dismissing don't think we'll
need that many that could be something
that could by the president later on but
for now he is continuing to take an
optimistic and upbeat tone yeah and
specifically on that tone Kimberly what
do we make of that because the president
has faced criticism from some people
saying that he's been slow and
ineffective in his response to the
crisis so far yeah there's no question
about it in fact and I don't want to
sort of get ahead of my colleague
Kristen salumi I know you we talked to
you with the financial markets but
certainly was a key factor that led to a
lot of anxiety in this country all
across the board the fact that there
seemed to be this feeling that the
president may have been even suppressing
the availability of tasks through his
government in order to artificially keep
numbers down of the outbreak in terms of
coronavirus here in the United States
now he was asked and that Rose Garden
press conference do you take
responsibility for that fact he said
just the opposite and don't take
responsibility for the lag in testing in
fact he tried to blame the previous
administration under Barack Obama saying
it was an outdated system not equipped
for this type of a pandemic they've
quickly adapted the system getting rid
of a lot of regulations allowing for
private labs to be involved in
coordination with the federal government
in order to try and combat this moving
forward saying they'll be set up for
success in the future I think it is a
message that at least for now until the
Americans see whether or not it actually
works I think many will find reassuring
all right Kimberly thank you for that
update from Washington well you heard
Kimberly mentioning markets a moment ago
and they did rally during President
Trump's announcement the Dow Jones
Industrial Average closed up 9.3% after
trading around three percent up for most
of the day Thursday saw the greatest
losses since the Black Monday crash of
1987 in London the footsie 100 initially
surged 8% but gains subsided and
afternoon trading to close just two
point four percent up it's tough
it's biggest weekly loss in more than 30
years and in Asia markets plunged and
warning trade but managed to call back
initial losses in Hong Kong the Hang
Seng Index closed down 1.1 percent let's
get an update from Krishna salumi
joining us from New York so how did the
markets react to what President Trump
had to say it was really interesting
during this press conference was timed
shortly before the markets closed less
than an hour before markets closed
President Trump made his remarks pushing
all three of the major stock indices up
over 9% regaining most of what they lost
on Thursday I think there were a couple
things that the president did and said
that investors found particularly
reassuring the first was talking about
increasing testing capacity in the
United States that was a big concern
across the board and in this country and
with investors in particular and he did
this surrounded by not only health
officials but corporate CEOs
representing companies like Walmart in
Google and Walgreens talking about what
was being done to increase testing
capacity and showing that businesses are
going to be part of that solution I
think that's something that investors in
particular will find very reassuring he
also announced that the Energy
Department would be buying up strategic
would be buying up oil to top off the
strategic oil reserves for the country
that was also something that the markets
found very reassuring oil prices which
had been plummeting went up a bit today
energy stocks which also had been
suffering as a result of lower demand
and a price war between the Russians and
the Saudis they went up today as well so
there was good news there for investors
sharp contrast to earlier in the week
when the president addressed the nation
and announced a travel ban restricted
travel from Europe to the United States
that sent the markets tumbling also he
announced that there would be a relief
package but it was very vague not a lot
of details they did not find that
reassuring at all so the president took
a more
and a specific tone and his remarks
today surrounding himself with all of
those professionals and has seemed to
work you know it's still not clear
whether or not Congress and the White
House will be able to get together and
what they're going to do in terms of a
relief package per se what will be
passed but for now
definitely calming fears the volatility
index for the markets which shows just
how jittery investors are has been
sky-high in the last week and it's down
at the close of the markets today down
25% so that's a sign that at least for
now
investors are breathing a sigh of relief
alright so Krishna salumi thank you